[موسيقى]
عل
the babies taken in the midle of the
night ي
احد را
حي
[موسيقى]
وم
في منتصف القرن الماضي وتحديدا خلال عام
1949 رحلت الوكاله اليهوديه نحو 50 ال من
يهود اليمن في عمليه اطلق عليها بساط
الريح داخل هذا الحدث العديد من الملفات
التي يمكن فتحها لكن ملفا واحدا تحرص
اسرائيل ان يبقى في الظل فقد اختفى قرابه
2في طفل من اطفال يهود اليمن فور وصولهم
الى معسكرات الاستقبال الاسرائيليه وما
زال مصيرهم مجهولا حتى اللحظه بالرغم من
مرور اكثر من 70 عاما على
اختفائهم
شوف انا رايي انحنا نمشي باكثر من اتجاه
الاتجاه الاول هو متى وصلوا كيف اختفوا
وانتهاء بما يحدث
اليوم هنا في بوستون سالتقي سوشانا مدمون
يهوديه من اصول يمنيه وهي استاذه جامعيه
كانت قضيه الاطفال موضوع بحثها في رساله
[موسيقى]
الدكتوراه
نحن نتحدث عن قصه صادمه اختفاء ما يقرب من
طفل وحتى اللحظه مصيرهم مجهول انت كباحث
ودرست هذا الملف تماما وكذلك لديك اقرباء
من الذين اختفوا في تلك
اللحظه هل ممكن تحدثنا عن قصتك الشخصيه مع
هذا الملف سواء في السياق البحثي او في
السياق الشخصي العائلي
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لي كانت مساله شخصيه للغايه ومع
ذلك فقد اردت ايضا ان اجعل منها ماده
للبحث واتعامل معها باعتبارها مساله
اكاديميه وهكذا فال المساله بالنسبه لي
بدات مع سماع قصص عمتي حمامه وسعده شقيقتي
والدي التين اخذ عنهما طفلهما في عام
1949 وبصوره خاصه فقد كان احداهن قصه
صادمه للغايه حيث انتزع طفلها من بين
ذراعيها هل هناك اي تفاصيل حول لحظه
الوصول تحبي انت انك
توثقها بعد تاسيس الدوله في عام
1948 وحتى عام
1949 نقلت الدوله جوا نحو 50 ال من اليهود
اليمنيين من اليمن وحين وصلوا الى اسرائيل
تم توطينهم في مخيمات استيعاب المهاجرين
تدعى المع بروت بالعبريه وبما انه تم
اسكانهم في اماكن مختلفه من البلاد في
مخيمات مسقوفه من الصفيح قيل لهم سيكون من
الافضل للاطفال لو اخذوا الى مساكن
الاطفال المبنيه من الحجر ستكون هذه
المساكن اكثر امنا للاطفال وبامكان
الامهات القدوم الى هذه المساكن وارضاع
الاطفال ثلاث مرات في
اليوم
لنقترب اكثر مما حدث التقينا العديد من
الباحثين والمهتمين بتتبع ملف الاطفال
المفقودين داخل
اسرائيل الدكتور توم بيسا يحمل شهاده
الدكتوراه في علم الاجتماع وخلال العشر
السنوات الماضيه عمل على البحث والتوعيه
والترجمه بما يخص قضيه الاطفال
المفقودين قيل لهم انهم ماتوا هكذا كان
النهج المتبع دون ان تتاح لهم رؤيه
الجثمان او يتسلموا شهاده وفاه وهناك
مؤشرات مختلفه على ان هؤلاء الاطفال لم
يموتوا على سبيل المثال في الحالات
القليله التي قاوم فيها الاباء وهددوا
الفريق الطبي لاحظنا ان الاطفال الذين قيل
انهم ماتوا قد بعثوا فجاه فاعاد الى
ابائهم وهم يرتدون ملابس جميله للغايه وفي
ما يبدو كانوا يجهزون لمنحهم الى شخص
[موسيقى]
اخر هات شيوعا لحالات الاختفاء كان
الاطفال يؤخذون في منتصف الليل دون موافقه
اولياء الامور وفي اليوم التالي يقولون
لهم انهم مرضوا ونقلوا الى المستشفى ومن
ثم لم يتم اعادتهم ابدا من هناك بل قيل
لهم انهم ماتوا وفي اغلب تلك الحالات لم
يرى اولياء الامور شهاده وفاه او قبرا بل
ولم يتسنى لهم اقامه عء
هم
بلغت ظاهره الاختفاء ذروتها عام
1950 ولدينا شهادات في موقعنا تقدر عدد
المختفين بنحو الف
طفل واعتقد ان الدكتور ناثان شس قدر في
كتاب له حول القضيه عدد المخفين بنحو 2000
طفل ونحن نعتقد ان هناك حالات لم تصلنا
وبالتالي الحديث عن بضعه الاف من
الاطفال
[موسيقى]
thank you introduction
جيمس اس توود باحث متخصص بدراسه الشؤون
الاسرائليه استوقفه ملف الاطفال المفقودين
وكان احد الملفات التي عمل عليها واقام
بشانها العديد من الفعاليات والندوات
اخرها معرض الاسره
الفارغه لاحظنا انه لديكم خط زمني يتوافق
مع البحث
الذي كنا نعمل عليه هل بالامكان ان تشرح
لنا اهم
محطات تطور قضيه الاطفال من خلال هذا الخط
الزمني يبين هذا المخطط ان الطريقه التي
ابعد بها الاطفال عن اولياء امورهم كانت
عمليه متعدده المراحل بدا هذا في مخيمات
المهاجرين في روشها عين وعين شمير حيث تم
ابعاد الاطفال من اولياء امورهم بطريقه
ممنهجه ومن ثم وضعهم في منازل ومستشفيات
خاصه بالاطفال لفتره
وم هناك يتم نقلهم غالبا في الليل ومن دون
ابلاغ اولياء الامور كان هذا يحدث في اغلب
مستشفيات البلدات والمدن الرئيسيه كافح
الاباء في محاوله العثور على اطفالهم في
تلك المستشفيات الا انه لم تكن تتاح لهم
المعلومات او الوسائل للسفر الى هناك وحتى
لو تمكنوا من الوصول فقد كانوا يقابلون
بعدائه ولهذا فهناك شبهات قويه ان العديد
من الاطفال الذين اختفوا قد تم في الحقيقه
اعدادهم للتبني بهذه الطريقه
والله خبر مش كويس للاسف الان الضيفه
اتصلت من يومين تتلقى مكالمات وتهديد لما
علموا انها يعني تظهر
معنا احنا محتاجين نعرف هذه الضيفه اللي
كانت متحمسه فجاه اعتذرت اليوم قبل
التصوير بساعتين لماذا اللي حصل هو قالوا
لا احنا ما نعمل المقابلات وانت اذا عملتي
سنقاطع احنا كنا نوصل مع اربعه فرق قبله
ووصلوا للنقطه اللي هي هذه ويهربوا هم
يختفوا من
الصوره تكرر معنا هذا الموقف كثيرا طوال
مرحله العمل على هذا الفيلم وبالرغم من
تمنع اهالي الضحايا عن الحديث الينا نجحنا
اخيرا بالوصول لمن فقدوا اشقاء
لهم باتيا اسحاقي فقدت شقيقتها راحيل لحظه
وصول عائلتها الى مخيمات الاستقبال في
اسرائيل عام
كتمت
اسمي باتيا اسحاقي ولدت في اليمن وصلت الى
اسرائيل عندما كنت في الخامسه من عمري بعد
ذلك ولدت رحيل كانت تبلغ من العمر 28 يوما
في ذلك الوقت قالوا ان الاطفال يجب ان لا
يبقوا مع عائلاتهم بل يجب ان يذهبوا الى
نزل الاطفال وامي كانت تذهب لارضاع مرات
عده منف
اليوم بينما كانت ترضعها اقتربت منها
ممرضه خطفت الطفله بقوه من بين ذراعيها
وركضت نحو سياره اسعاف كانت تنتظر في
الخارج ذهلت امي وقفزت مباشره لمطار تلك
المراه لكنها لم تستطع اللحاق
بها
بالتوازي مع حرصنا على الوصول لاهالي
المفقودين كان الارشيف الاسرائيلي الرسمي
وجهتنا للحصول على اكبر قدر ممكن من
الوثائق الخاصه بقضيه الاطفال المفقودين
بين ايدينا وثائق خاصه بعائله باتيا وهي
عباره عن بطاقه تعريفيه تصرف لكل قادم الى
اسرائيل من اليمن او غيره نجد مكتوبا في
هذه الوثيقه تاريخ وصول العائله في الث3
من نوفمبر عام
199 4 وهنا وثائق اخرى تتعلق باسعاف
الطفله المفقوده ونقلها من بيتها الى
المستشفى ومن ثم وفاتها حسب وصف
الوثيقه شموئيل
ماوده تكشف لنا التفاصيل التي اوردها لنا
عن شقيقته المفقوده ان هناك نمطا واحدا
لاختفاء
الاطفال امي كانت تحكي لنا انها كانت طفله
جميله
ومعافه وكانت تذهب
ارضاعها وكانت تضعها في سرير
هزاز وعندما عادت في اليوم
التالي وجدت السرير فارغا وصارت تنادي اين
رحيم
قالوا لها انها ماتت دون ان يرف لهم
جف واخذت تسال اين
جثتها اين الجثه ان كانت قد
ماتت وابي المسكين كان متالما جدا هو
الاخر قال لهم ان كانت قد ماتت على الاقل
اعطونا
جثتها هؤلاء اناس بلا
رافه وبلا قلب وبلا ض
امي وابي حتى مماتهما كانا يفكران دوما
انهما سيلتقيان بها كان على امل لرؤيتها
حتى اللحظه الاخيره لكن لم يتحقق لهما
[موسيقى]
ذلك ولم يشعر بطعم الفرح منذ ذلك الحين
كان في حاله حداد
دائم التقطت هذه الصوره من داخل الطائره
التي كانت تقل يهودا من عدن في جنوب اليمن
الى دوله اسرائيل الجديده حيث نقل عبر جسر
جوي حوالي 50 الف يهودي في غضون ثلاثه
اشهر ما يمكنك رؤيته بوضوح في هذه الصوره
هو ان التدخل والسيطره على الاطفال كان قد
بدا قبل وصولهم الى دوله
اسرائيل هذا يعني بان اخذ الاطفال من
اهاليهم كان مخطط له من قبل ان يصل
الاطفال الى
اسرائيل اذا قرات وثائق المنظمات التي
اشتركت في عمليه نقل اليهود من اليمن الى
اسرائيل فمن الواضح انهم كانوا ينظرون الى
الاطفال باعتبارهم اثمن ثروه تجلب الى
الدوله الجديده وقد جرى العمل وفق هذا
المبدا في كل المؤسسات التي تم انشاؤها في
اسرائيل سواء كان في مخيمات العبور او
المستشفيات او مراكز الاطفال انه نفس
المنطق على طول
المساء هذا النمط المتكرر للاختفاء
يطرح امامنا العديد من الاسئله لكن السؤال
الاكثر الحاحا اين ذهب هؤلاء الاطفال وما
الدوافع وراء
اختفائهم في اسرائيل قابلنا هداس زيف
ناشطه تعمل في منظمه اطباء من اجل حقوق
الانسان تتبعت ملف الاطفال المفقودين
وخصوصا ما يتعلق بدور المؤسسات الطبيه
لحظه اختفاء
[موسيقى]
الاطفال هذا سؤال المليون دول
ماذا كان دافع المؤسسه والمجتمع الطبي في
ذلك
الوقت هذا سؤال معقد
للغايه من الواضح انه كان هناك مجرمون
حولوا هذه القضيه الى عمل
تجاري يحاول البعض في المجتمع الطبي
الدفاع عن القضيه بالقول اردنا ان نفعل
الخير لقد جاء هؤلاء الافال من منطقه كانت
تعاني من سوء التغذيه ونحن اردنا ان
يعيشوا ترى هنا اطفالا يمنيين تحملهم
ممرضات بملابس بيضاء ونساء من امريكا جئنا
لزياره المستشفى ويبين هذا بوضوح ان
السياح من امريكا كانوا يمتلكون فرصا افضل
للوصول الى اولئك الاطفال اكثر من امهاتهم
اللوات كنا ينظرن من الخارج ولدينا شهادات
من الممرضات كنا يعملن في المخيمات تفيد
بانهم شاهدوا نساء اجنبيات في سيارات
فاخره يخرجن بالاطفال لهذا من الواضح ان
هؤلاء النساء اتيحت لهن الفرصه للوصول الى
هؤلاء الاطفال اكثر بكثير من امهات
الاطفال
نريد ان ننتقل للامام فاين ذهب الاطفال
واين ذهبت
العوائل لا يمكن فهم هذه القضيه ما لم
يؤخذ في الاعتبار دور العنصريه فنحن ازاء
اشخاص معظمهم من اوروبا يقررون مصير اطفال
لعائلات من الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
والبلقان لذلك فهناك بعد عرقي لا ينكر في
احكامهم في كل مره يقررون فيها ما اذا كان
من الاف لهؤلاء الاطفال العوده الى
عائلاتهم او ارسالهم الى مكان
اخر الاجابات التي نحصل عليها تطرح العديد
من علامات الاستفهام اكثر مما تفسر
الاسباب المنطقيه وراء ما حدث في هذه
المرحله من التحقيق توجهنا الى سان
فرانسيسكو لمقابله الدكتوره سمدار لافي
وهي عالمه انثروبولوجيا يهوديه
لباتها الصه حول ما حدث
للافال ما هي الدلاله التي تكشفها هذه
العنصريه يعني لماذا يحدث ذلك هل هذا
الجزء من بنيه العقل الاسرائيلي ام
ماذا ربما من الافضل ان ابدا بالطرح اطار
مفاهيمي لتناول القضيه ينطلق هذا الاطار
من الاقرار حقيقه ان الصهيونيه منحت
اليهود وطنا في فلسطين وكان يهود اوروبا
هم من ابتدع فكره اقامه دوله يهوديه
وديمقراطيه وهذا من قبيل التناقض ان تكون
هناك ديمقراطيه تفترض تفوقا
لليهوديه وداخل منظومه التفوق هذه ثم
علاقات عرقيه قائمه بين اليهود من البلدان
الناطقه باليدي شيه او الاش ناز واليهود
الذين جاؤوا من العالم الاسلامي
والعربي لهذا ولكي تكون مواطنا في اسرائيل
فان المواطنه تقوم على اساس الديانه
والعرق وهو امر في غايه الفاشيه ولان
تبديل الدين يعد امرا في غايه الصعوبه في
اسرائيل ينبغي ان تثبت ان اصولك لخمسه
اجيال كانت يهوديه من جانب الام بهذا
المعن اذا كنت اشكنازي بلا اطفال فمن
الافضل ان تتبنى طفلا يهوديا لا تشك في
يهوديته او كما يقول المثل العبري يهوديه
بلا شبهات اليهود الشرقيون ولا سيما يهود
اليمن لم يتزاوج خارج الطائفه وبالتالي
فان المراه على ثقه تامه من ان اطفالهم
يهود انقياء وهم لذلك ينسجمون مع نموذج
المواط القائم في
اسرائيل لماذا هذه
النظره الاستعلائي في لحظه احتياج يعني
هذه دوله تؤسس نفسها وتحتاج لهؤلاء ان
ياتوا ومع ذلك ينظرون اليهم هذه النظره
الاستعلائي اغلب الاوروبيين عند وصولنا
كانوا يفرضون هذه السياسات وينظرون نظره
استخفاف الى كل الاشخاص الذين اتوا الى
اسرائيل من العالم العربي
يبقى السؤال قائم لماذا تفعل اسرائيل ذلك
لماذا تريد لهؤلاء الاطفال ان يعيشوا لد
عواء
الاخرى سالت احدى الممرضات كيف تفعلين هذا
وتستطيعين النوم في الليل قالت لي ربما
قدمنا لهم معروفا لقد قمنا بهذا لان هناك
عائلات دون اطفال وتريد اطفالا ليس ذلك
فحسب بل هناك سيده اجريت معها مقابله
اخبرتني بان الطبيب قال لها انها هؤلاء
اطفال لطفاء لكن ليس لعائلاتهم المال
الكافي لرعايتهم ولهذا فكروا بهذا الشكل
وهو بالمناسبه تفكير استشراقي وعنصري
للغايه حول من يحق له ان يكون وليا للامر
ومن لا يحق له
ذلك في الواقع ان وجود اطفال يهود من اصول
شرقيه يجري الاتجار بهم اوي
يعد عملا مربحا لانه لو كنت يهوديا
اشكنازي بلا اطفال ولا تريد ان تواجه
مشكلات مع قوانين المواطنه فستفل ان تحصل
على طفل يهودي الايديولوجيه الاخرى هنا
تعتبر العرب والمسلمين اناسا بدائيين لا
يستخدمون موانع الحمل ولذلك لديهم عائلات
كبيره ويمكنهم الاستغناء عن طفل واحد او
طفلين بش ان يكون لون بشرته فاتحا هذا اذا
هو المنطق وراء الاتجار او بيع اطفال يهود
باعتبارهم مواطنين انقياء في الدوله
واسرائيل لديها ما اسميه هيستيريا
الديموغرافيا نعلم عن طفل احضره يفال الون
كهديه تماما كما يتبنى كلب فقد ذهب الى
احد نزل الاطفال واحضر طفلا لعائله ارا
ها قبل التصوير قلت بان هذه القصه هي
واحده من قصتين يمكن ان تؤدي الى اسقاط
اسرائيل لماذا تعتبري هذه القصه بهذه
الدرجه من
الخطوره لو عرف العالم حجم العنصريه
السائده داخل مجتمع اليهود لن تحظى
اسرائيل بذلك القدر الكبير من التعاطف
خصوصا من المجتمع اليهودي الغربي ذلك لان
مسائل خطف الاطفال وبيعهم للتبني او اجراء
تجارب طبيه غير مسرح بها على الاطفال
والكبار تعتبر فضائع عنصريه بهذا المعنى
لو اصبحت كل هذه الامور معروفه لدى اليهود
الشرقيين فانهم سيشك في صلاح اسرائيل كوطن
[موسيقى]
لليهود
اختفى الاطفال وذهب ذووهم بلا اجابات غير
ان حدثا مفاجئا بعد اكثر من 16 عاما من
لحظه الاختفاء اعاد لاهالي المفقودين قلق
السؤال والحنين لمعرفه مصير
اطفالهم
بعد سنوات تعيش مع هذا الجرح ولا تعرف ما
هو مصير ابنك ولكنهم قالوا لك انه مات
ولنفترض انك تصدق ذلك ثم يصلك امر التجنيد
العسكري فاي فوض هذه لقد قلتم انه مات حتى
لو حدثت فوضى حينها اين وثيقه الوفاه اين
القبر اين اختفت كل السجلات وكيف تصدرون
له امر
التجنيد من خلال التفاصيل اطلعنا عليها
هناك من يقول بانه الاباء والامهات بداوا
باكتشاف حقيقه القصه او باحتمال ان
اطفالهم مازالوا على قيد الحياه بعد فتره
من الزمن عندما جاءت اليهم رسائل عبر
البريد تطالبهم بان يذهب هؤلاء المفقودين
الى الجيش هل كانت هذه اللحظه الكاشفه لما
حدث اجل منحهم املا فعدم محو اسمائهم من
السجلات منحهم املا في ان الاطفال ربما لا
يزالون على قيد الحياه ولا سما انهم لم
يسجلوا كموتى لانهم لو كانوا موتى لما
بقيت اسمائهم في تلك السجلات ومن هنا
بداوا يتسالون لماذا اسمائهم لا تزال في
السجلات وكانهم احياء وصل رجال الشرطه
العسكريه الى منازل العائلات ليسال وهم
اين هذا الطفل وكان هذا انذارا لاولياء
الامور بانهم امام كب ومن ثم بدا المجتمع
اليمني ينظم
نفسه شكلت هذه الاحتجاجات تحولا فارقا فقد
نتج عنها تشكيل اول لجنه تحقيق عرفت بلجنه
بهلول منكوفسكي دشنت عملها عام
1967 واستمرت حتى عام
6 الا ان نتائج التحقيقات جاءت مخيبه
للامال فبدا الاهالي بالاحتجاج مجددا
واضطرت السلطات الاسرائيليه مره اخرى الى
تشكيل لجنه جديده عام
1988 عرفت بلجنه شالج واستمرت في عمليات
التحقيق حتى عام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في هذه الحقبه ظهرت شخصيه كان لها دور
بارز في مسار القضيه عوزي مشلام حاخام من
يهود اليمن اسس حركه احتجاجيه للمطالبه
بالتحقيق في هذه القضيه وتناقلت و الاعلام
تصريحاته حاصرته الشرطه مع اتباعه لفتره
تلاه اقتحام ادى الى اعتقاله ومقتل احد
اتباعه ثم حكم عليه بالسجن قبل ان يفرج
عنه بعفو من رئيس الحكومه
انذاك التقينا دفن
بيرام التي اطلعت على تفاصيل هذه القضيه
خلال عملها في وقت سابق كمحام ومترجمه
وكان له علاقه مباشره مع عوزي
مولام تحدث معنا بانك قابلت عوز مش شلام
وهو احد الشخصيات المهمه في هذا
الملف ماذا تعرفي عنه وماذا حدث
معه عوزي مشلام كان حاخاما نجح في تنظيم
منظمه صغيره تضم ناشطين من الذين كانوا
يسعون لكشف حقيقه اختفاء اطفال اليمن
بدا نشاطه في
السبعينيات الا ان شهرته الاساسيه او
سمعته السيئه بلغت اوجه في
التسعينيات حينما خرج اتباعه متظاهرين في
الشوارع واشتبكوا مع الشرطه وقد وقع
الكثير من الاشتباكات بين اتباعه
والشرطه انت قابلت مشلام وكان لك حديث معه
ما الذي جرى في هذا
الحدث كنت اؤمن فعلا ان اطفال اليمن قد
اختطفوا الا انه حينما ابلغني المحامي
الذي كنت اعمل معه والذي عاده ما كان يمثل
الفلسطينيين امام المحاكم العسكريه بانه
قرر فجاه ان يكون محاميا لموشا لم استحسن
الامر ترددت وشعرت ان الرجل فيه شيء من
الجنون ومحيطه لا يحظى باجواء ذاتي
مصداقيه الى انني كنت مبتدئه ومتدربه في
المكتب فوافقت على العرض كنت اشعر بالفضول
ايضا لانها كانت قصه مشهوره وكبيره فذهبت
لزيارته في السجن ويجب ان اقول انني خلال
الفتره التي ترافع عنه فيها قرات الكثير
من الشهادات فاصبحت مقتنعه اكثر فاكثر ان
الرجل واتباعه يملكون وجهه نظر صع
بعد هذه الموجه من التصعيد تاسست لجنه
كوهين كدامي عام
1995 واستمرت تحقق في القضيه حتى عام
[موسيقى]
2001 لم تشك اللجان في عمل النظام لان
القضاه والاطباء ينتمون لل
لذلك فان ما نجح فيه م هو دفع الدوله الى
تعيين لجنه تحقيق اخرى مع ذلك تبقى الشكوك
قائمه عندما تختفي الملفات قبل يوم واحد
من طلب اللجنه رؤيتها او عندما يندلع حريق
مفاجئ او يتم فجاه اتلاف
الادله نحن اطلعنا على عمل هذه اللجان من
خلال الارشيف الاسرائيلي نفسه ووجدنا ان
هناك الكثير من
الارشفه
والتتبع
لتفاصيل هذه القضيه ولكن المفارقه ان
النتيجه النهائيه التي تنتجها هذه اللجان
تذهب باتجاه تبرئه السلطات الاسرائيليه
انتم كباحثين
كيف تقيمون عمل هذه
اللجان العديد من وث الارشيف التي كان من
الممكن ان تكون ذات اهميه قصوى لعمل
اللجنه فقدت او دمرت قبيل الجلسات في حاله
اخرى لدينا نسخ من الوثائق الارشيفيه ولكن
يتم حذف اسماء الاطفال او تنقيحها ما يجعل
من الصعب جدا استخدامها للوصول الى
الاستنتاجات التي نرغب فيها لهذا يبدو
واضحا بالنسبه لي ان هناك رغبه من جانب
اولئك الذين كتبوا تقرير اللجنه لتقديم
اجابه مفادها انه لا يوجد ما يدعو للقلق
لقد اخبركم بالحقيقه ربما تم ايصالها ال
بطريقه خاطئه من قبل لكن يمكننا الان ان
نؤكد لكم ان القصه التي قيلت لكم قبل 70
عاما كانت صحيحه وان اطفالكم ماتوا
[موسيقى]
للاسف وماز
و منذ ذلك الحين ظللنا نبحث عنها مثل
الاخرين ذهبنا الى كل لجان التحقيق
وال الى الشه وكنها لم تدنا ظللنا نحصل
على نفس الاجابات طوال الوقت بان الطفل
مات لا شيء اكثر من
ذلك باتيا سليمان كانت احد الذين جرى
استدعاؤهم من قبل لجان
التحقيق اجل لقد حضرت الى لجنه كدامي
واعتقد ان القاضي تشيش كان هناك اجل كان
هناك وطرح علي كل انواع الاسئله
واجبت اخبرته بكل ما حصل ولكني اعتقد ان
لا احد دون ما قلته بشكل سليم قال لي
القاضي تيشن اعتقد ان اختك ما تزال حيه
ومنمن هم على قيد الحياه الحقيقه هي ان
القاضي تيشن كان شخصا طيب القلب وكان يريد
المساعده لكني مقتنعه بان يديه كانتا
مقيدتين انا متاكده من ذلك كانت عمليه
تبييض فقط ولم تكن هناك لجان حقيقيه لقد
قاموا بذلك حتى يقولوا انهم فعلوا شيئا ما
لكنه شيء بلا
قيمه اذا عدنا للمحطه
الاولى كان هناك
دور مريب للمؤسسات
الصحيه حيث انها هي من تاخذ هؤلاء الاطفال
من ذويهم فهل كان لهذه المؤسسات الصحيه
دور مباشر ام انها لم تكن تعلم بان هؤلاء
الاطفال
سيختفون انتشرت في المستشفيات تقارير
كثيره تتحدث عن الزحام وعن حضور عدد كبير
من الاطفال الى المستشفيات في ظل عدم توفر
اسئله كافيه لهم ومع ان العديد من اولئك
الاطفال كانوا اصحاء الا ان المستشفيات
عوضا عن اعاده الاطفال الى ذويهم لجات الى
حلول اخرى بسبب عدم ثقتهم في قدره اولياء
الامور في العنايه بهم لذلك بداوا
يتواصلون مع الخدمه الاجتماعيه ومع
المنظمات النسائيه خاصه فيسو المنظمه
النسائيه الصهيونيه العالميه ومن ثم بداوا
يرسلون من خلالهم العديد من الاطفال الى
مراكز رعايه الاطفال في المدن الكبرى مثل
تل ابيب وصفد والقدس كما نعلم هذه
المؤسسات كانت في ذلك الوقت مؤسسات مهمه
للغايه في ترتيب عمليات التبني لهذا فان
كثيرا من حالات اختفاء الاطفال يشتبه بشده
انه قد تم في الحقيقه تبنيهم عبر هذه
الطريقه بدات مشاركه المؤسسه الطبيه من
خلال الممرضات والاطباء الذين كانوا
يعملون في المخيمات واخرجوا الاطفال كما
تشمل سيارات الاسعاف التي نقلتهم
والمستشفيات التي رتهم ومن ثم قطعت
الاتصال باولياء امورهم في بعض الحالات
التي يموت فيها الاطفال يصعب ان نعرف اي
طفل مات بالضبط ومن اخذه لان كل ذلك ح دون
ابلاغ اولياء امورهم ودون توثيق ما حصل
وكذلك الامر في الحالات التي تعافى فيها
الاطفال فقد كانوا ينقلون الى دور رعايه
كتلك التي كانت تشرف عليها فيتو مره اخرى
كان يحصل ذلك دون ابلاغ الوالدين ومن دون
اجراءات اشرافيه تضمن عوده كل طفل الى
والديه طوال فتره العمل على هذا التحقيق
ونحن نحاول الوصول لوجهه نظ الجهات
الرسميه في هذا السياق قابلنا البروفيسور
ايمار جروتو والذي شغل مناصب قياديه عديده
في وزاره
الصحه الخلاصه النهائيه حول هذا الموضوع
انه كان هناك نشاط للعاملين في النظام
الصحي واريد ان اقول هذا بعنايه فائقه لان
الحقائق المتصله بها ما تزال محل نزاع
ولهذا ابدا بوصف الحقائق العامه التي
حولها اجماع واسع الواقع ان مهاجرين من
اليمن وبلدان اخرى استخدموا الى هنا
المهاجرون الاوروبيون كانوا ايضا يصلون
الى هذه المخيمات المؤقته التي تعرف
بالمعبر وهذه المخيمات كانت تعاني من
ارتفاع معدلات الاصابه بالامراض وسوء
التغذيه والعديد من المشاكل المرتبطه
بالفقر والكثافه السكانيه المرتفعه الى
جانب الاوبئه التي كانت منتشره في عم
اسرائيل في ذلك الوقت ولهذا ينبغي النظر
في كل هذه الامور باعتبارها السياقه
العامه
للقضيه السؤال اللي دائما يحضر في بالي
اثناء البحث هل كانت السلطات الاسرائيليه
تقوم بهذا الفعل بشكل ممنهج ام انه كان
نتيجه للظروف وكان يحدث بالصدفه او كا
اخطاء
فرديه
من الواضح ان هذا كان مخططا منهجيا ولا
يمكن ان يكون خطا
فالخطاب مره واحده وليس امرا يتكرر
مرارا ونعرف من التجارب الاخرى ان الاضرار
الكبيره تحدث حينما يتم تقنينها بصوره
منهجيه سواء كان ذلك في قضايا العنصريه او
اضطهاد المر
ا الاقي او حقوق
العمال هناك من يقول ان ما
حدث كان خطا عرضي او خطا فردي هل هناك ما
يدل على انه عمل ممنهج قامت به السلطه
الاسرائيليه
في الحقيقه كانت شبكه محكمه التنظيم ولهذا
فقد كان عملا ممنهجا كما اوضحت من قبل
واللجان تسترت على الامر لان لديهم اباء
او ربما لديهم اطفال بالتبني او لديهم
خالات او اخوات ممن عملنا في الخدمه
الاجتماعيه واعطينا الموافقه على التبني
لكل ذلك فالمؤسسات باكملها تعاطت في
الحقيقه مع عمليه الاتجار
بالاطفال استطيع ان اقول بكل ثقه ان
اولياء امور الاطفال كانوا في البدايه
يتلقون العلاج في المخيمات ولكن احيانا
اخرى كان الامر يتطلب نقل الطفل الى
المستشفى وفي هذه الحاله يؤخذ في سياره
اسعاف كانت المستشفيات بطبيعه الحال بعيده
للغايه وبالتالي كان على الوالدين السير
على الاقدام لرؤيه اطفالهما في افضل
الحالات كانوا ياتون مره واحده في اليوم
الى جانب ان لديهم اطفالا اخرين للاعتناء
بهم اذا قمت باخراج طفل من ذويه دون
موافقه والديه ثم لم تعده اليهم ولم تشرح
لهم وتعطيهم الروايه الكامله لما حدث لذلك
الطفل فانك تعتبر قد اختطفته ولهذا اعتقد
انك اذا نظرت الى المنظومه فسترى نمطا
واضحا وحزمه من المواقف ورابط واضحا بين
متلف المؤسسات ومجموعه من الاولويات
الواضحه لنقل الاطفال بعيدا عن والديهم
وتقديمهم للمؤسسات التي كانت تعرض الاطفال
للتبني وهذا يدل على وجود نمط من الاختطاف
المؤسسي فلم يكن الامر من قبيل المصادفه
ولم يكن خطا انما كان نظاما وعلى النظام
ان يخضع
للمحاسبه كانت فتره معقده للغايه كانت
هناك فوضه مع ذلك اعتقد قبل كل شيء ان
التسجيل الطبي وتدوين الملاحظات يعتبران
جزءا من العمليه الطبيه وبالتالي فقدان
بعض تلك السجلات الطبيه مشكله في حد ذاته
لم تكن هناك فوضى في مخيمات اللاجئين ولا
في مخيمات عبور اليمنيين او المغاربه لقد
كان الامر منظما لدرجه انه اذا فقد الناس
عند خروجهم من المخيم ملعقه صغيره كان يتم
محاسبتهم
عليها ميدانيا ومن داخل الكنيست
الاسرائيلي تمكنا من توثيق تصريحات حاسمه
في ملف الاطفال المفقودين ادلى بها عدد من
اعضاء الكنيست كان الصادم لنا انها تؤكد
وبلغه قطعيه شهادات الباحثين واهالي
المفقودين في عام
1952 وصل جده يوسف مع زوجته وابنته راشيل
الى منطقه اوردا لزياره بعض افراد العائله
لم تكن صحه راشيل البالغه من العمر عامين
يومها على ما يرام فاخذوه الى مستشفى في
تلهو شمير في المستشفى قيل لوالدي رشال
انها وعكه صحيه طفيفه لكن يجب ان تبقى
راشيل في المستشفى لليله واحده حينما
عادوا في صبيحه اليوم التالي قيل لهم ان
الطفله قد ماتت لكن لم هناك شهاده وفاه
ولا وجود بالطبع للجثه بعد ذلك حاولوا
لاسابيع عده الحصول على اي مستند او
توجيههم الى القبر هذه قصه واحده من بين
مئات والاف القصص وعلى الرغم من حدوثها
منذ عقود الا ان الجرحى مازال ملتهبا ولا
تزال العديد من العائلات تجهل مكان تواجد
الاطفال وتنتظر ردا رسميا او ادله على ما
[موسيقى]
حدث
انني استخدم هذه المنصه المهمه في الكنيست
لاطلب منك العفو يا حخام مشلام ارجو
عفوك لان دوله اسرائيل سخرت منك واضطهد تك
ومع انك يا سيد مشلام لم تتمكن في حياتك
من رؤيه النتائج لكن كفاحك لم يذهب سد
واحتجاجات لم تذهب سدى صحيح ان الامر
استغرق وقتا طويلا لكن الجميع يدرك الان
انك كنت على صواب وان احتجاج كان صحح الان
العداله في صفك والالام التي عبرت عنها لم
تكن نتاج خيال فقد حصلت بالفعل اشياء
فظيعه لقد كانت هناك سياسه اخفاء ورغبه في
تبيد واخفاء الامور التي
حدثت ما هو المطلوب من اسرائيل اليوم حتى
تخرج من هذا المازق وتغلق هذا
الملف امين لاكون في الجانب التشاؤمي اع
بانه سيكون هناك حل مع ان تاريخ الماساه
يتم نقله من جيل الى جيل الا انه مع الاسف
لا ارى انه سيحدث تغييرا هيكليا في
التشكيل العرقي او في الترابيه العرقيه
القائمه في
اسرائيل لا يمكن انكار الماساه التي تعرضت
لها العديد من
العائلات مكن تحقيق الاعتراف والعداله
وتضميد الجراح لم يختفي الاطفال من تلقاء
انفسهم وانما اختفوا بفعل فاعل قام
باخفائه بشهاده العديد من الناس مؤخرا نشر
بحث اجراه الدكتور دانييل دي ملاخ يشير
فيه الى الاخفاق الرئيسي في اعمال اللجان
التي حققت في القضيه حيث اكتشف ان شهادات
الوفاء والدفن مشكوك فيها للغايه ويمكن
اعتبار الجزء الاكبر منها خاطئا او
مزيفه اضافه الى ذلك اكتشف ان لجنه
التحقيق قد خدعت المجتمع فبدلا من الكشف
عن المشاكل المتصله بالوثائق وتوضيح سبب
اعتمادهم عليها برغم كل ما فيها اقرت
اللجنه مزاعم كاذبه وكانها حقيقيه لا
تشوبها شائبه رغم ذلك فان هذه التحقيقات
التي اجرتها هذه لجان وكشفها الاعلام اعطت
صوره قاتمه عن الاهمال والعنصريه والتجاهل
التام للعائلات
[موسيقى]
ما اورده عضو الكنس عوفر كاسيف حول تزوير
الوثائق يؤكده ما تتبعنا داخل الارشيف
الاسرائيلي الرسمي فعلى سبيل المثال
لاحظنا ان عددا من شهادات الوفاه اصدرت
اثناء عمل لجان التحقيق وليس وقت الوفاه
[موسيقى]
المزعومه من اخر التطورات في هذا الملف هو
انه الحكومه او مجلس الوزراء في عام 2021
اصدر قرار تعويض لعائلات هؤ ما رايك بهذه
الخطوه خاصه انها كانت مصحوبه بطلب بان
هذا التعويض مشروط بان تسكت وتصمت هذه
العوائل ولا تتحدث عن القضيه مره
اخرى رد فعلي هو انها طريقه اخرى لمحاوله
اغلاق الملف فبدلا من قول الحقيقه
والاعتذار وطلب العفو علنا يحاولون
التواصل مع عائله واحده في كل مره بهذه
الطريقه يقولون لهم خذوا بعض المال ثم
التزموا
الصمت هناك طريقه استخدمت في اغلاق قضيتي
سعفه الراس ولقاح الجمره الخبيثه يعاد
استخدامها هنا بالقول خذوا تعويضا ماليا
ثم اصمتوا ثم ستقول الدوله انها ذهبت الى
اقصى مدى ممكن لتحقيق العداله وانها لن
تتحمل اي مسؤوليه كلا فالامور لم تعد تسير
على هذا ح لان ذلك يشبه الرشوه لابقا
صامتين التعويضات المقترحه هي من الاشياء
التي عرضتها الحكومه لكن ليس لها اي تاثير
لان العديد من تلك العائلات لم تتواصل مع
لجان التحقيق وبالتالي لم يتم الاقرار
بوفاه اطفالهم ولذلك
فالتعصب الذين اقرت اللجان بوفاتهم هناك
تعارض بين المعلومات التي تقدمها الحكومه
وتلك التي تملكها
العائلات
امل ان ينجحوا هذه المره وان تقرر الحكومه
اخيرا فتح كل الملفات بشكل صحيح فنحن نريد
معرفه
الحقيقه التعويض المالي هل يسخرون منا
بعرض حفنه من المال اليس هذا وصمه
عار ولا اختي نسعى للمال شقيقتي الكبرى
التي كانت تبحث معي توفيت كنا نتوقع كل
يوم ان ياتينا اتصال او ربما
رساله نشرنا اعلانا بضع مرات للبحث عنها
لكن لم
يفيدنا
م
ح هل تعرف معنى ان يعيش المرء مع هذا
الوضع انه مثل جرح في القلب يابى ان
[موسيقى]
يندمل
بعد عامين من البحث والتحري بقينا بالقرب
نتابع تطورات القصه على الارض وكان اخر ما
وثقنا في هذا السياق هو احياء مجموعه من
العائلات للذكرى السنويه لاختفاء
[موسيقى]
الاطفال
c